part is a celebration yeah that's what  it's about  last year we couldn't meet up but this  time it's allowed with my queer friends  and allies now it's time to go out  we get to do it all again now we're out  on the floor but i don't see my crush  he's not texting me back well i'll just  brush it off i have a mental breakdown  make my friends take care of me and i  think  okay so they made the bold choice to be  not funny  once again it's a bold strategy cotton  by the way i hope all the people in that  sketch are actually gay otherwise this  would be appropriation which is very  offensive  i'm guessing they're probably safe as  far as that goes out of all the funny  and controversial things they could have  done with a gay pride  skit  this is what they do instead i'm not  even sure what the joke is supposed to  be all my queer friends and allies  that's hilarious yeah that's not funny